العملية البرية التي بدأت
منذ عدة أيام رأينا
أسلوبا جديدا في الهجوم الإسرائيلي أثناء محاولتنا
الوصول إلى غزة الآن ما رأيناه حتى الآن
هو هجوم من أماكن مختلفة
عادة استراتيجي عسكري أه حاول أن
أه أظهر للعدو أنهم يهاجمون
من أماكن مختلفة دون الكشف عن مكان
الهجوم الرئيسي
ولكن رأينا من الشمال
أه الشرق ومن بداية أه
وادي غزة الذي يفصل بين الشمال
والجنوب في جبهتين مختلفتين
وهجومين مختلفين لكن
المثير  في هذه الهجمات من
الشمال الشرقي هناك فجوة كبيرة تبلغ أكثر
من كيلومتر وهي عبارة عن مساحة فارغة مفتوحة لا
يوجد بها سوى بضع مئات من
الأمتار بعد جدار
غزة حيث يمكن للإسرائيليين الاشتباك مع
المقاومة الفلسطينية ولكن في
المنتصف  الهجوم الذي جاء على
جبهة أخرى حيث يوجد وادي غزة،
لدينا 600 لدينا أكثر من ستة
كيلومترات من المساحة المفتوحة الفارغة
حتى يتمكنوا من الوصول إلى هذه الشعاعات تصل إلى
المنازل الأولى الآن د تدمير
المنازل بالطريقة التي يتبعها الإسرائيليون
بشكل منهجي و
القصف العشوائي على غزة أه
يتحول في غير صالح إسرائيل
لأن لديهم كل الثوار
والحطام على الأرض في كل
الشوارع وهذا يمثل مخبأ
وكمين للمقاومة الفلسطينية
لا يمكن أن يحلموا به علاوة على
أنه يوقف الميكانيكي الإسرائيلي  تقدم
بدباباتهم لذا عليهم إزالة
كل الحطام الذي عليهم أه ملء
الثقوب التي أحدثوها
بقنابلهم الكبيرة وكل ذلك
سيستغرق الكثير من الوقت مما يعني بالنسبة لنا
أنهم لم يتعاملوا بشكل كامل بعد
مع  بداية الخط الدفاعي
للمقاومة الفلسطينية ولهذا
السبب قطعوا الإنترنت وقطعوا
الاتصال بين غزة وبقية
العالم حتى لا يرى العالم
الفظائع التي يرتكبونها ولا
يرى ذلك عملياً استراتيجياً  لم
يحققوا أي شيء حتى الآن،
ولا أرى أن الجيش الإسرائيلي
متردد حقًا في الذهاب إلى غزة
والمشاركة في المقاومة،
وهذا تغيير كبير
لا يريد الجيش الإسرائيلي أن نراه من بعيد
ونخبره به.  أخبرنا أنهم يخشون
المغامرة أكثر داخل غزة حيث
يتعين عليهم القتال مع الإسلاميين
والمقاومة الفلسطينية التي
أعدت لهذا الهجوم البري هجومًا
مضادًا يعتمد بشكل أساسي على
الأنفاق التي حفروها كلها تحت
غزة